peu
[Musique]
bonsoir beaucoup de monde comme vous le
voyez sur le plateau du studio sein ou
en direct nous ouvrons les guillemets
pour la deuxième fois beaucoup de monde
est pourtant le plus prestigieux de nos
invités n'est pas encore là arthur
rubinstein qui ne tardera pas seul à
faire de quelques minutes mais vous avez
peut-être aperçu au passage
roger garaudy jean pierre melville henri
fresnay etc etc grande semaine
académique
comme vous le savez avec deux élections
jeudi ont dit que monsieur andré roussin
sera probablement élue et monsieur jean
dutourd peut être élu c'est important
vous savez les élections l'académie
depuis que on y choisit les ministres
des affaires culturelles car comme vous
le savez notre nouveau mini des affaires
culturelles et monsieur maurice druon de
l'académie française
et puis aussi hélas cette semaine c'est
la semaine de la mort de pablo picasso
dans une émission qui porte en sous
titre magazines des livres et des idées
il est bien évident que nous devons
faire sa place à pablo picasso
d'abord parce que il y a des livres sur
picasso il y a des il ya délit il ya des
livres deux picasso et puis picasso
était un artiste engagé et enfin picasso
était un formidable chahuteurs de forme
est un créateur d'idées
ce n'est pas monsieur roger garaudy et
qui me contraintes qui me contredira
monsieur roger garaudy publié en 1963
avec un grand succès car son livre
suscite à de nombreux commentaires il
publiait d'un réalisme sans rivage dans
réalisme dans un réalisme sans rivage il
parlait de picasso de saint john perse
et de kafka et à propos de picasso il
écrivait application nous a peut-être
appris à lire dans son langage plastique
la loi de notre siècle
monsieur moi j'ai garaudy je crois que
vous êtes toujours d'accord est ce que
vous écriviez il
bientôt dix ans la loi de notre siècle
mais je crois qu'elle se résume tout
entière en une image celle par exemple
de son guernica le voilà notre monde
cassé éclaté ce cheval né presque le
symbole ou par un artifice de
perspectives multiples on peut voir tout
l'éclatement de ses flancs sous toutes
ses formes dans les tirs mans du corps
de cette femme dans la déformation
volontaire de ce genou qui permet
d'accentuer la chute de la femme qui
tombe dans les flammes
c'est à dire que ceux créés à travers ce
tableau une série de tensions
une série de distorsion c'est une scène
d'apocalypse
et pourtant ce tableau ne nous inspire
pas un sentiment de défaite ou de
désespoir et ceci pour des raisons
plastique
il est composé comme un retable anciens
voyez avec un premier panneau qui se
terminerait ici un volet qui se
terminerait avec le taureau un autre qui
se termine ici si vous voulez replier
vous avez exactement un retable et de
même vous avez cette triangulation dont
le sommet est sûre la lampe et qui
permet de faire une deuxième
tripartition du tableau c'est à dire
tout ce passe comme si pic à sion nous
disait dans son langage plastique
il y a le chaos mais il ya une force
humaine capable de le surmonter
vous pensez bien qu'une telle manière de
peindre n'est pas seulement une manière
de pain c'est une manière de vivre et de
ce point de vue il me semble que picasso
représente
je ne dis pas seulement dans l'histoire
de la peinture dans l'histoire tout
court peut-être l'un des artisans de
l'une des trois grandes mutations de
notre civilisation européenne si vous
voulez la première c'était le moment de
dix ans la peinture byzantine et qui
nous représentait le monde vu du point
de vue de dieu à la fois par ses
couleurs ses or ces bleus ses formes
immuable ses perspectives converger vers
nous comme un appel lui un défi de dieu
et puis le renversement qui s'opèrent à
la renaissance avec photos où cette fois
il n'ya plus seulement des symboles d'un
autre monde mais les objets prennent une
consistance un volume une pesanteur et
où l'homme devient le centre est la
mesure de toute chose le
depuis du point de vue de l'homme est la
troisième grande mutation c'est celle de
picasso
cette fois il ne s'agit plus d'une
réalité qui seraient toutes faites
je crois que le grand enseignement de
picasso c'est de nous montrer que le
monde c'est une réalité en train de se
faire et que nous avons à faire il nous
montre là qu'il y a plusieurs mondes
possibles et qu'il est de notre
responsabilité de les faire et je crois
de ce point de vue qu'il n'y a rien de
plus révolutionnaire que de nous aider à
nous placer du point de vue du créateur
autrement dit picasso était engagé à
double titre au fond il n'est pas
seulement révolutionnaire parce qu'il a
dit un jour avec juste raison je suis
allé au communisme comme on va à la
fontaine mais je crois qu'il est partout
de son oeuvre par cette possibilité
d'arrachement réel par ce défi permanent
que nous lance son oeuvre de continuer
la construction du monde et de ce point
de vue ils ramènent par-delà six siècles
de tradition européenne
il ramène la race et plus grande source
c'est à dire non pas simplement
reproduire des apparences du visible
mais rendre visible l'invisible si vous
voulez dans un masque africain
on capte des énergies de la nature ont
les irradiés ensuite par les prestiges
la justice de la danse et bien je crois
qu une oeuvre de picasso
c'est un noyau de réalité plus dense et
une image comme celle là est précisément
l'image de notre siècle et je crois
qu'il nous fait faire l'apprentissage de
la création voyez vous il est dit dans
la bible et après le septième jour dieu
regarde à son oeuvre est dit cela et
bien et bien je crois que si caractérise
picasso c'est d'avoir peut-être pris la
relève d'un dieu qui seraient trop vite
satisfaits de nous montrer qu'il reste
quelque chose à faire que cette création
est à continuer l'explication est au
fond pour nous l'homme du huitième jour
de la création dès que vous rejet
garaudy qui pouvaient citer la bible à
vos de pablo picasso j'en suis sûr est
ce que vous connaissez aussi picasso
homme de théâtre auteur dramatique
vous savez quand on est poète c'est dans
toutes les dimensions et je crois que
ces poèmes je réalise tout ce théâtre
surréaliste la saison théâtre ça c'est
les quatre petites filles et puis ça
seul essai personnel
cette façon de rendre poétique deux
choses par leur simple rapprochement
comme lorsqu'il prend
un guidon de vélo et il selle de vélo il
en fait le but c'est femme lorsqu'il
prend une caisse c est qu il en fait un
ventre de chèvre
lorsque avec il nous fait une grue avec
une pelle robinet c'est là je crois
cette imagination pourrait-il nous
regardons ensuite avec défiance ce vélo
ce ou ce robinet parce que il prend un
sens nouveau c'est une métaphore de la
vie et c'est ce que nous voudrons chez
lui s'il n'avait pas été un grand
peintre il aurait probablement été un
grand poète comme van gogh par ces
lettres nous montre qu'il aurait été
aussi un grand écrivain s'il n'avait pas
été un grand peintre
je vous signale à propos de poésie que
pablo que les éditions gallimard ont
publié un recueil de poèmes de pablo
picasso en septembre octobre prochain
sont des poèmes écrits vers 1935 à
l'époque sur réalise de picasso au
moment de l'écriture mécanique
automatique et ses poèmes sont les cris
tantôt en français tantôt en espagnol et
certains sont traduits par pierre daix
et alejo carpentier est d'ailleurs dans
un livre de pierre daix intitulé tout
bonnement picasso l'homme et son heure
est aux éditions somogy et bien on peut
apercevoir je ne sais pas si la caméra
nous montrera bien un poème de picasso à
écriture automatique vous voyez deux
écrits de sa propre main avec des
majuscules
cela montre bien que l'art est
indivisible et je crois que l'acte de
création artistique qu'il s'agisse de
poésie ou de peinture est au fond le
modèle de l'acte même de la pensée je
dirais de l'acte politique aussi de
l'acte révolutionnaire c'est pourquoi
l'esthétique n'est pas un moyen de
prendre ses distances à l'égard de la
politique c'est au contraire cet effort
et picasso et un ce qui nous renseigne
le plus profondément et c'est par là que
sonnaient profondément révolutionnaire
à seulement 28 ans mais dans la vie à
nous placer de ce point de vue de
l'homme créateur nous apprend que
l'homme est trop grand pour se suffire à
lui-même
merci roger garaudy
[Musique]
et
oh
moi
[Musique]
une note dany échos les noms bien connus
en dehors
non non non
[Musique]
la présence du colis soient gentils
dehors pour cible en fin
[Musique]
respiratoires fois musique avec ça
je vous je vous interromps oui pardonnez
moi mais ce clown n'est pas tout à fait
un clown comme les autres c'est aussi un
écrivain et oui c'est aussi un écrivain
vous êtes écrivain marie noëlle péloquin
car vous avez publié tout récemment aux
éditions du seuil un roman qui s'appelle
picholine pourquoi picholine parce que
si mon nom de piste ça vient d'eux c'est
jerry mon partenaire qui l'a trouvée
parce que comme on en sait peu loquace
et paul hawkins et de collines enfin des
choses comme ça puis aussi ça rappelle
que je suis né dans le pays du bon vin
ce que tu calling c'est à dire un peu
picolé qu'est ce que vous dites dans ce
dans ce roman je raconte des histoires
enfin une histoire une histoire d'amour
c'est encore à la mode
et puis je raconte aussi le voyage et la
promenade lé village et puis tout ça
mais pas le cirque alors comment être
doux venu clown
comment devenir clown en apprenant en
apprenant un métier
mon mari lui l'a appris du vieux
constant ogier qui était beaucoup plus
âgée que lui y est moi je l'apprends de
lui dans la tradition c'est amusant non
c'est très dur parce que dans votre
livre vous paraissez indépendante même
assez volonté c'est le malheur je suis
indépendante et il faut beaucoup de
travail pour arriver à faire un métier
dans le dans le cirque
vous travaillez tous les jours par
exemple la musique ça me kg après toi le
déneigement m'a fallu un temps fou saxon
pourtant c'est cette eau facile il faut
beaucoup répéter enfin il ya des choses
que ce ne sont moins difficiles que la
musique vous avez le trac
maintenant quand je suis en piste
maintenant quand vous êtes en piste en
piste donc attendre travail en cire que
tous les jours après non plus puisque
l'hymne vous connaissez ce livre
d'hélène par moment non mais je crois
qu'il est sorti hier pendant qu'un bluff
notre source cette semaine c'est
d'hellemmes parmelin le contre pitre
avec sous titres entrée de clown alors
c'est un livre je crois qui vous ira
droit au coeur parce que d'un effet de
saynètes où l'on retrouve le clou de
majorettes le kunar pète le coup je
crise le kun convertit les madame hélène
par mail est d'une certaine manière un
cloud écrivains comme vous pourriez
d'ailleurs fondé une association des
clowns écrivain et curieuse rencontre
c'est qu'elle n parmelin vous savez
peut-être connaît très bien implication
connais très bien l'oeuvre de picasso et
elle a écrit deux ouvrages sur picasso
qui font autorité c'est picasso sur la
place
et puis ce livre aussi picasso dit on
trouve aux éditions gonthier
ami entends tu le vol noir des corbeaux
sur nos plaines
ami entends tu les cris sourds du pays
qu'on enchaîne
oui partisans ouvriers et paysans c'est
l'alarmé
ce soir l'ennemi connaîtra le prix du
sang et des larmes monter de l'avim
descendez des collines camarades sortait
de l'appareil les fusils la mitraille
les grenades
oui les tueurs à la balle et au couteau
où tu évident
oui saboteur attention à ton pardon
dynamique c'est nous qui brisons les
barreaux des prisons nos frères
la reine à nos trousses et la foi qui
nous pousse la misère ya des pays où les
autres délits font des rêves si nous
vois tu nous marché nous tue concret le
chant des partisans
l'occupation les années noires c'est le
cadre du livre dont je vous parle ce
soir
ce livre relate relate une histoire qui
commence le 27 juillet 1940
ce jour là ce soir là plus tôt dans une
chambre de sainte maxime
il ya un homme qui rédige des notes cet
homme c'est un officier il était sur la
ligne maginot il y a peu de semaines
encore et il a été fait prisonnier enfin
fait prisonnier dans son cas il faut
dire que ça n'est pas un personnage
qu'on capture facilement à peine est-il
prisonniers que déjà il s'évade et le
voilà parti à travers la france à
travers une france qui farci de troupes
allemandes et il arrive à sainte-maxime
chez sa mère cet homme s'appelle henry
freiner et le livre qu'il publie
aujourd'hui comble en quelque sorte une
sorte de vide dans l'histoire de la
résistance parce que il a eu beaucoup de
livres sur la résistance certains
vraiment tout à fait remarquable tout à
fait excellent mais henry freiner lui il
n'avait pas parlé jusqu'ici or or ce
manifeste ses notes qu'il rédige ce soir
du 27 juillet elle prépare précisément
la résistance il organise tout seul dans
sa chambre une armée une armée dont il
est jusqu'ici l'unique soldats il est à
la fois le général et le soldat de cette
armée mais la graine qu'ils s'aiment ce
jour là c'est une graine qui va lever
puisque il en sortira le mouvement
combat le mouvement combat avec tous ces
chapitres c'est à dire avec le
renseignement avec la propagande avec
avec la résistance fer avec les groupes
de chant or aujourd'hui enfin ce blanc
ce vide qu'il y avait dans l'histoire de
la résistance et comblé puisque henry
freiner se décide à publier ses
souvenirs ses souvenirs s'appelle la
nuit finira il
ils paraissent chez robert laffont c'est
un livre dur c'est un livre qui ne mâche
pas ses mots et on peut déjà imaginer
qu'il fera grincer un certain nombre de
dents mais pour l'instant ça n'est pas
exactement sur cet aspect que je
voudrais m'attarder je voudrais parler
en tant que livre simplement pour parler
de son ton de son accent c'est un livre
qui se lit véritablement avec passion
pourquoi avec passion parce que henry
freiner nous donne à voir cette province
de l'ombre qu'était la france occupée il
nous donne à voir la vie quotidienne des
résistants cette vie qui est humble et
qui est dangereuse à la fois ce sont les
rendez vous clandestin en particulier à
lyon dans des cafés sur les bancs d'un
square dans une porte dans une porte
cochère il nous donne aussi à comprendre
ce que fut la passion de ses hommes ce
que fut leur héroïne ce que je leur peur
aussi avec les exécutions avec les
trahisons autour d'eux avec les tortures
il nous montre aussi qu'il y avait parmi
ces hommes parmi ces femmes qui
bordaient sans cesse la mort ils n'ont
qu'à véritable juin une véritable
exaltation aussi celle de la fraternité
et d'ajouter c'est que celui dont sommes
nous restitue tout un immense de notre
passé il nous montre des hommes qui
parfois pas comme des silhouettes
furtives
ils ont disparu ces hommes nous savons
plus ce qu'ils sont on a d'autres on ne
sait même pas ce qu'ils furent c'est à
dire il ya des anonymes ci qui sont des
personnages du livre il y en a moi qui
m'impressionne beaucoup un soir henri
fresnay est à son bureau à son bureau de
lyon à son pc donc de combat et il
reçoit un coup de téléphone il ya une
voix au téléphone qui lui dit henri
fresnay demain matin de très bonne heure
monsieur x va venir vous voir va venir
vous voir je vous le répète de très
bonne heure et vous m'avez compris et
henri fresnay dit oui j'ai compris bien
sûr l'avez compris monsieur x était le
chef de la police de lyon henry freiner
prend ses cliques et ses claques les
bureaux de combat disparaît ce n'est
qu'ils étaient ceux qui s'y étaient sept
voix mystérieuse au téléphone
aujourd'hui encore nul ne le sait en
plus de tout cela henri freiner nous
conduit d'un théâtre de la guerre à
l'autre c'est à dire qu il nous conduit
de lyon à marseille de marseille à
toulouse
de toulouse à paris mais aussi de lyon à
londres par exemple et là il ya un
voyage pour qu'ils se situent en 42 il
me semble qu est assez fascinant parce
que d'un jour à l'autre
le tableau change complètement c'est à
dire que lyon c'est la résistance c'est
vraiment le combat de l'ombre ce sont
des hommes seuls des hommes traqués et à
l'ombre contraire à réfréner arrive dans
une ville qui est évidemment
profondément mutilé mais qui est une
ville
libre alors le contraste est vraiment
saisissant d'un côté ce sont ces soldats
ces soldats qui vont tant bien que mal
tout seul qui cherchent tout de même à
travailler mais ils se connaissent mal
entre eux il y à des liaisons difficile
et de l'autre côté au contraire cette
immense machine de guerre qui ronronne
avec régularité
et si je m'attache à cet épisode pour
terminer ça n'est pas seulement à cause
de son romanet c'est parce que je crois
que cet épisode revêt une signification
politique après tout après tout s'il y a
eu des divergences entre les hommes de
l'intérieur et puis les hommes de
l'ombre
peut-être est-ce aussi parce que il y
avait une distance sidérale entre les
hommes de londres et les hommes de
france
il y avait des siècles de distance d'une
certaine façon entre les deux guerres
ces deux guerres qui se tramait ensemble
qui était la même game qui avaient des
volets des aspects différents d'un côté
c'était les hommes de l'état major
c'étaient des hommes qui conduisaient la
guerre en scientifique et de l'autre
côté c'était des hommes qui peut-être
sortait des écoles de ta majeur mais qui
en tout cas était de toute façon obligé
d'être des sortes de deux soldats de
l'an ii et il fallait qu'ils réinventent
la vieille guerre des humiliés et des
offensés il fallait qu'il invente la
guerre révolutionnaire la guerre
subversive et peut-être une partie de
l'incompréhension entre londres et la
résistance vient de cette distance voilà
ce qui pour moi est une des choses
importantes dans le livre d'henri
freiner bien sûr c'est un livre
d'histoire important il met des choses
au point c'est en outre un livre
polémique que je crois vraiment qu'il va
faire flamber les passions il devrait
les faire flamber pour mon compte ce que
je retiens tout de même peut-être
d'abord peut-être avant tout cela c'est
que il donne à entendre la lointaine
rumeurs de
résistance il ressuscite de il
ressuscite de vieilles images de
vieilles images qui nous reviennent
grâce à lui et tout soudain du fond de
la nuit
henri fresnay de nos côtés et riffs
rennais est-ce qu'il faut vous dire ce
minispace vous avez été ministre pendant
ce temps un tirage qui a pas pénalisés
par là je vous dirai ça monsieur et je
me pose cette question comment vient
t-il à l'idée d'un militaire de carrière
de fonder un journal ça c'est quand même
une curieuse idée pour un militaire
n'ont pas tellement car à l'époque
partout on nous mentaient vichy mentez
ou se taisait il fallait donc trouver le
moyen d'essayer de dire la vérité et de
la répandre cela des besoins les plus
pressants
nous avons ressenti notamment en zone
libre
malheureusement nous n'avions aucun
moyen
j'étais moi même un demi soldes et les
camarades que j'avais recruté autour de
moi étaient pauvres
cependant elle a commencé parce qu'il
faut toujours commencer par un bout et
ce bout ça a été tout simplement à vichy
au début de l'année 41 une machine à
écrire à distance ça paraît risible
alors on a fait une frappe hideuse
frappe ici frappé dix frappes
harry berty albrecht c'est comme ça que
très modestement nous avons commencé et
si je vais je me reporte deux années
après deux ans et demi après la même
organisation qui dieu merci c'est est
d'étoffer publiés je pars dans la
meilleure époque c'est-à-dire celles où
la gestapo n'avait pas porté de coups
trop rude sont quatorze imprimerie en
même temps un volume de papier des
petits papiers d'ailleurs qu'ils
représentent est parfois un million
d'exemplaires par mois
mais naturellement on n'a pas atteint sa
en un jour
il y a fallu du temps beaucoup d'efforts
et beaucoup de sacrifices
alors après la machine à écrire nous
nous sommes passés à la ronéo comme vous
le voyez le cycle normal
alors au lieu de dix frappes pendant la
fécule y ont tiré à 500 à 800 à 1000
exemplaires
mais comme notre gagner sur le
développer que la demande augmente et
que les régions que nous avions tant
bien que mal constitué on demande est de
plus en plus de nos papiers
alors un jour nous nous sommes dit il
faut passer à l'imprimerie je vous avais
bien je crois une bonne surprise pour
vous vous parlez à un moment dans votre
livre de monsieur martin est imprimeur à
lyon à villeurbanne exactement exact
monsieur martin a été le premier
imprimeur du premier numéro de combat on
peut dire même s'il était je crois sans
me tromper le premier imprimeur les
journaux de la résistance
peut-être pas enfin dans ce sens l'un
des promus à toute chose à sa pâleur
plaisir et bien je suis allé à
villeurbanne pour voir monsieur martin a
bien longtemps je ne les ai vus monsieur
martin est cette machine sur laquelle
vous travaillez c'est la machine sur
laquelle a été imprimé le premier numéro
de combat clandestin
le premier arrêt est précédé par petit
zèbre et vérité et le racontez moi dès
février 41 commandes devient ton un
imprimeur de la résistance pas vraiment
évidemment évidemment que je n'étais pas
pour
ni pour les allemands ni pour pétain
même étant d'ailleurs anciens du parti
socialiste est alors comment vous avez
été contacté mais j'ai été contraite
contacté par madame berne ti halbreich
par l'entremise de mon camarade dargaud
qui est d'ailleurs mort en déportation
et henri fresnay
vous l'avez vu henri fresnay j'ai vu
deux trois enfants kim et cherchait ses
imprimés et housari pour un capitaine
d'aviation charger les porter les
valises pleines a pris mais ce n'était
pas du sucre mais est d'ailleurs assez
peut-être le premier ministre que j'en
ai chronique que j'ai vu porter des
valises et quel était votre nom de
résistant monsieur martinez combat ils
ont cherché longtemps avant de l'appeler
du pot est ce que vous voulez nous
montrer comment vous un premier combat
est vain
voici une première passe lafarge est une
une deuxième phase la page 2 une
troisième phase la passe droit et une
quatrième place
il terminait l'imprimé évidemment les
compositions étaient différents la une
deux trois quatre
et alors quand j'ai été arrêté par la
police française
ils ont été et non plus retenu le
l'imprimeur clandestins parce que
j'imprimais deux fois plus grand que la
machine était jarret c'est ce qui m'a
permis de ne rester que quelques heures
en prison donc le premier numéro de
combat avec quatre pages et vous l'avez
tiré à combien d'exemplaires
environ 5000 si mes souvenirs sont bons
mais vous aviez quelqu'un pour vous
aider pour faire tout ça
oui oui c'est vrai ma femme vous pouvez
dire d'ailleurs qu'on a été constamment
à côté de moi pour la résistance et du
mien
madame martinet vous étiez donc la
collaboratrice de votre mari dans cette
activité fort dangereuse à savoir un
primeur de la résistance
parlez nous de la peur de l'angoissé
d'être arrêté formé en faisait quand
même notre travail et vous monsieur
martinez ont narré constamment pas mes
envies vers cette habitude
c'était normal on n'espérait pas de
cadeau beaucoup de monde passer par
votre imprimerie vous et beaucoup
beaucoup et beaucoup qui ont été arrêtés
qui nous ont jamais dénoncés et depuis
la guerre ce que beaucoup de gens
reviennent vous voir des gens qui
passait à ce moment là où très peu très
peu on en deux ou trois peut-être alors
qu'ils étaient combien pendant la guerre
une multitude à nous demander des
services et vous avez été récompensés
par des décorations
obama au début monsieur freinet nous a
même à des mafias awa à la recette de la
résistance que j'ai d'ailleurs jamais
porté parce que ma femme a été oubliés
on l'avait proposé pour la croix de
guerre
monsieur manque ministre socialiste l'a
refusée elle la méritais pas alors
depuis ce moment-là j'ai rompu avec les
décorations
henri fresnay nous venons de voir donc
un de ces hommes qui ont participé à la
résistance et qui ensuite sont rentrés
dans l'obscurité mais vous à votre
manière qui est différente
est ce que ce n'est pas un petit peu le
même cas c'est à dire que vous avez été
ministre des prisonniers réfugiés et
déportés ou peut-être est-ce dans un
autre ordre qu'il faut dire ce titre
jusqu'en 45 je crois vous n'avez plus
occupé de fonction officielle
vous n'avez pas écrit jusqu'à
aujourd'hui donc il ya eu tous même un
immense laps de temps dans lequel vous
êtes rentré vous aussi dans l'ombre
pourquoi oui c'est vrai je suis rentré
dans l'ombre comme vous dites pour deux
raisons principales la première c'est
que les rêves que nous avions formé
pendant la résistance avec beaucoup de
nos camarades sont pas réalisées nous
avions espéré dans une certaine mesure
essayer de formuler les traits d'une
société plus juste meilleur plus
généreuse très différente en tous les
cas de la troisième république et la
quatrième république à pion de nos voeux
n'avaient que peu le rapport avec celle
qui arrêtent est né sous ce même titre
et ça je les ai vues dès la fin d'année
45 moment de l'assemblée constituante
je savais que le régime qui naissaient
seraient frappés de stérilité
j'aurais pu me présenter aux élections
bien sûr c'était facile j'étais ministre
en fonction
je n'ai pas fait et puis aussi il ya une
autre raison qui vous paraîtra peut-être
un peu puéril parfois les gens disent de
moi je suis un naïf je n'accepte pas ça
du tout comme une injure je dirais
presque plutôt comme un compliment parce
que j'avais appris dans la vie politique
qui ressent trop souvent à une jungle
faut beaucoup se battre alors se battre
contre les ennemis le coup irrégulier et
j'ajoute que je ne déteste pas mais
quand une formation politique il faut
commencer par se battent parfois avec
contre ses amis
et si possible les démolir à défaut de
record les démoli par eux
alors ça c'est un jeu pour lequel je
suis pas douée et comme je tiens
beaucoup à l'amitié dans la vie j'ai
préféré l'amitié voilà pourquoi je suis
rentré dans l'ordre puisque vous êtes à
nay et je vais vous posez moi à mon tour
une question naïve
c'est à dire au départ en 40 vous êtes
donc cet homme seul cet homme seul qui
qui organise une résistance à venir
et puis des hommes vous rejoignent et
puis vous former un groupe vous allez
former le mouvement combat mais ce
groupe ce mouvement au départ il mène au
fond sa guerre il mène une guerre
solitaire et le temps passant cette
guerre que vous veniez ou ce combat
plutôt que vous veniez il rejoint le
reste de la guerre alors si vous voulez
à quel moment se sont produits les
premiers contacts entre vous et les
hommes qui dirigeaient la guerre depuis
londres en particulier aux aspects
souvenirs sur ce point là sont
extrêmement précis et la scène que j'ai
vu à côté se situe le 2 janvier 1942
dans une petite cuisine de la rue kléber
à marseille où vivent et agnès bedot
la soeur le georges la soeur de georges
j'y venais parce qu'on avait appelé pour
y rencontrer un homme que j'avais vu
aussi sim auparavant mois de juillet et
cet homme s'appelait jean moulin je ne
savais pas alors qu'il reviendrait on
disait qu'il était revenu
je suis arrivé dans cette cuisine
accompagné de mon vieux camarade bertin
chevance et nous avons rencontré jean
moulin avec l'émotion pourrait deviner
c'était le premier contact avec ce monde
est extraordinaire et inconnus qui est l
angleterre en guerre nous sommes tombés
dans les bras l'un de l'autre et à ce
moment là il a sorti de sa poche une
boîte d'allumettes et de cette boîte
d'allumettes il a sorti deux tout petits
papiers
c'était des microfilms il y avait en bas
du premier obtient une signature un peu
longue
la connaissais pas c'était c'était c'est
de gaulle
charles de gaulle c'était sorte de
mission il devenait responsable pour
l'ensemble de la zone libre de la
coordination des mouvements qui
s'étaient créés alors nous étions forte
ému mais nous avons été très heureux
lorsque sa poche revolver il a sorti non
pas un pistolet mais 250 mille francs
il a posé sur l'évier on ne l'avait
jamais en vue et j'ajoute qu'on en avait
un très très grand besoin
ce qui nous a fait moins plaisir s'il y
avait en plus dans les microfilms des
instructions qui était à vrai dire des
ordres avant même de la garde et j'étais
quelque peu surpris que le premier
contact établi entre londres et new
strahm se traduisent par des consignes
alors qu'on nous connaissaient pas et
par conséquent gens réduisaient assez
logiquement qu'on ne savait pas
exactement ce que nous faisions alors ça
c'était le point de départ d'une très
longue histoire que je raconte dans mon
livre et qui a eu de nombreuses
péripéties
en définitive qui a marqué je crois
pouvoir le dire sans forcer les termes
une assez grande incompréhension entre
les services français de londres et la
résistance et les mouvements de
résistance nous n'étions pas nous ne
considérons pas comme aux ordres il y
avait 18 mois qu'on travaillait seul
avec nos propres ressources en inventant
nos méthodes en inventant l'eau forme
d'organisation en recrutant ne sommes
nous avions quand même droit au chapitre
quel était donc ses ordres alors
nombreuses péripéties bien sûr qui ont
duré des années qui ont eu parfois des
crises très violentes notamment au
moment où emma qui se crée beaucoup plus
tard au début de l'année 1943 et où les
ressources pour le distribuer qui avait
largement augmenté ont été brusquement
réduite alors que les mac qui appelait
au secours
nous avons cherché par d'autres moyens
de l'est procurée on nous en a empêchés
j'ai connu des scènes très dures
les altercations très violente avec jean
moulin est l'une des autres altercations
avons eu très grave étions dans la
création du conseil national de la
résistance que ce serait une trop longue
histoire racontée mais qui a eu je crois
pour la france les plus funestes
conséquences je crois si vous résumer
d'un mot qu'il y a eu d'une manière
générale je schématise et peut-être je
caricature qu'on veut bien m'en excuser
qui a eu
incompréhension méfiance et dans
certains cas rivalité je crois que là
prenez un ton polémique d'un seul coup
c'est évident est d'ailleurs un joli
vraie polémique c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai et vous nous empêchez pas et il y à
là autour de vous quatre résistants qui
ne sont peut-être pas tout à fait de
votre avis ils assurent certains
rapports londres résistance il y à
claude bourdet journaliste ancien
conseiller de paris et auteur de à qui
appartient paris marcel de guillame chef
du service de coproduction albert tf
hauteur avec henri noguères d'une
histoire de résistance dont trois
volumes sont parus alors vous vous étiez
quoi dans la résistance
eh bien j'ai d'abord commencé par être
avec bollier dans l'imprimerie que vous
avez vu tout à l'heure
chargée de l'impression et de la
diffusion de combat puis ensuite j'ai
été chargé de mettre sur pied ce qu'on
appelait l'action ouvrière qui était qui
avait pour but de constituer dans les
usines à travers toute la france des
groupes de sabotage
ensuite je suis devenu responsable de la
commission d'action immédiate pour toute
la zone sud et puis j'ai terminé comme
responsable national déco from la
libération qui bordaient et bien j'ai
été un des membres du comité directeur
de combat j'ai été responsable politique
l'adjoint politique de freiner jeu j'ai
été aussi le créateur
enfin j réunis ensemble et donner un
corps à ce qui s'est appelé le naples
est le fondateur
le noyautage de lustration public bon et
puis j'ai été après le départ de freiner
alors le représentant de combat au
comité directeur du mouvement uni et au
conseil national de la résistance et en
même temps à la direction politique du
journal combat jusqu'à mon arrestation
44 le général de bénouville
député de paris président de jours de
france et auteur du sacrifice du matin
vous et vous faisiez quoi un mouvement
bien j'ai commencé au lendemain de la
défaite à travailler avec un mouvement
qui était en liaison directement avec
les anglais s'appelait radio patrie puis
j'ai rallié henri fresnay
il m'a donné mission créer le service
national extérieur de la résistance ce
que j'ai fait quand freiner a étendu les
services que pouvait rendre ce service à
l'ensemble des mouvements de résistance
j'ai continué à le diriger puis quand
freinée est partie pour londres
il a été remplacé par claude bourdelle
et par mois au comité directeur des
mouvements unis de résistance et c'est
ainsi que se seront passés ces actes et
enfin monsieur de vabres un
administrateur de société mais plus
connu sous le nom de colonel passy
pendant la guerre et auteur de trois
livres de souvenirs sur la résistance à
londres et vous étiez le chien des
services bref du bcr a c'est à dire les
services secrets du général de gaulle
par la guerre colonel passy vous venez
d'entendre les propos que henri fresnay
vient de tenir sur les relations entre
dombes et les zones de l'intérieur
il est possible que vous ne soyez pas
tout d'un coup tout à fait d'accord avec
ces propos je voudrais que vous ne
répondiez là dessus je ne peux pas être
d'accord avec lui moi pour mon ami henry
j'ai l'impression que l'incompréhension
qui veut bien donner ce n'est pas sale
véritable problème mais d'un problème
c'était une question de point de vue
moi j'étais à londres auprès du général
de gaulle et par conséquent charge et
essayer d'organiser au maximum l'effort
français intérieur à la fois pour que
tous les efforts qui seraient faits en
france soit portée au crédit de la
france
d'une part le diamant qu'il n'y ait pas
d'efforts inutiles
mesure où sera était possible et que
tous ses efforts en fin de compte
aboutissent à faciliter l'effort de
guerre il est absolument évident que la
part des anglais qui conduisait la
guerre et qu'ils l'ont conduite seul
jusqu'à la fin 1941 il souhaitait que
toutes les actions soit des actions plus
ponctuelles que celle que je serais peut
être souhaité en france donc la première
mission que j'ai eu à ferrer des
d'organiser le service de renseignement
parce que ça c'était capital pour les
abeilles sur l'armée allemande
et deuxièmement de commencer à mener un
certain nombre d'actions ponctuelles
pour détruire des objectifs particuliers
qui étaient signalées par l'état-major
anglais et troisièmement de monter les
organisations qui permit au jour de la
libération
dd a paralysé les déplacements de
l'armée allemande pour les empêcher de
venir sur le front au moment où
débarquent rennes donc en fin de compte
si vous voulez pour résumer je pense que
j'ai entendu souvent cette phrase
pendant la guerre surtout dans certains
milieux qui était la libération
nationale est inséparable de
l'insurrection nationale est bien
évident que delon ne pouvions pas voir
le problème comme ça car à partir de
londres
ce qu'il fallait c'était avoir un
concours maximum et le moins division
possible venant de russie parce que le
débarquement aurait été extrêmement
difficile et plus il y aurait eu de
tapage en france de remue ménage en
france
plus il y aurait eu d'armé allemande qui
aurait été ici et plus le débarquement a
été difficile sinon impossible
oui mais vous nous présentez là au fond
deux visions stratégiques qui sont
antagonistes une annonce mais est ce que
en outre dans cette incompréhension est
peut-être monsieur freiner peut me
répondre
quelqu'un de vous dans cette
décompression il n'est pas le fait que
au fond vous ne vous connaissiez pas
c'est à dire que vous étiez de même vous
battiez sur deux planètes différentes au
départ je crois qu'on se connaît on sait
tout de même bien connu à partir de
connu et je dirais très estimé ce que je
voudrais dire à freiner et
ils ont depuis longtemps c'est que je
pense qu'il aurait été à ma place il
n'aurait pas pu agir autrement j'ai agi
et j'aurais été à l'as ne suis pas gouré
partager absolument son point de vue
c'est la de bordés est ce que vous avez
une opinion à ce sujet oui je sais je
suis d'accord avec freinage suis pas
d'accord avec tout ce qu'il dit dans son
livre en particulier je suis tout à fait
d accord avec son interprétation des
mobiles de jambes ou la télévision
non mais par contre je suis tout à fait
d'accord et je crois que toute la
résistance intérieure les mouvements et
bénouville de glee à moi même dieu sait
que nous étions politiquement différents
à cette époque maintenant déjà avec lui
de rythme mais mais nous étions tous
d'accord freiner jean pierre lévy tout
le monde à des nuances près d'ailleurs
c'est dit dans le livre l'histoire la
résistance et tu le répètes henry dans
son livre tout le monde était d'accord
sur ce fait que nous étions en désaccord
avec les bureaux de londres
je crois en effet qu'il ya une question
de point de vue et qu' il y a je donne
raison qu'aurait si il était difficile
de voir les choses autrement quand on
était à londres et il était impossible
de voir autrement quand on était chez
nous le malheur c'est que comme c'est
londres qui avait la direction et
l'argent londres pendant tout le temps à
essayer de imposé à la direction de la
résistance qui étaient autonomes
autocéphale qui était né d'elle-même qui
était né de la terre de france et pas
d'une notion d'une direction de londres
londres n'imaginais même pas que ça
prendrait cette allure les mouvements de
résistance qu'ont essayé de nous imposer
leurs points mais je crois finalement
qu'il ya un dernier point c'est que tout
cela dépend aussi du caractère personnel
de de gaulle qui est bien défini par
l'art bureau quand il a dit un jour que
de gaulle ne voulait concédé à personne
aucune parcelle de la légitimité
française qui lui appartenait
entièrement
eh bien il était obligé d'une certaine
manière de partager avec la résistance
et ne pouvait concevoir autre chose que
des soldats un buisson et pas des alliés
ce que nous étions je crois que
peut-être néral de bénouville peut
répondre à ce que vos ennemis à
l'origine de notre soulèvement contre
l'invasion il y avait le fait naturel du
trio this moi qui pendant plusieurs mois
et travailler directement avec un
mouvement contrôlé par les angles comme
radio patrie j'ai pu m'apercevoir qu'à
londres même cette rivalité existe et
ceux qui venaient de l'ombre à l'époque
peter churchill et les ombres nous
recommandé formellement de ne pas
prendre contact avec les mouvements
français bien entendu à contrôler tu
m'as volé des troupes dans les alpes
maritimes
exactement on nous dit que nous
pourrions courir le plus grand danger
et finalement quand radio patrie s'est
effondré à la suite de différents
événements et que j'en ai rallier un
certain nombre d'éléments à combat nous
sommes aperçus que ce qui nous
opposaient à lons d'une façon générale
c'était le désir du contrôle tu as très
bien dit henry mais en fait un contrôle
qui aller très loin puisque par exemple
dans mon activité qui consistait à faire
franchir les frontières à des courriers
nous avons eu pour objectif principal
d'éviter et d'épargner la vie de nos
radios en câbles ont le moins possible
au telegraph y en le moins possible mais
même cela n'était pas tolérés par l'ons
on nous disait en donnant aux alliés par
exemple en suisse vous renseignement
lorsqu'il arrive à londres ils ne sont
pas crédités à la france libre parce que
nous voulions nous c'était par exemple
que châtellerault fut bombardé le jour
où c'était nécessaire et notre ami pacy
qui nous connaissaient bien puisqu'à la
différence de beaucoup de gens des
bureaux de l'ong lui est venu nous
rendre visite au péril de sa vie et à
plusieurs reprises savez bien qu'en
définitive si nous y tenions tellement à
ce poste s'est rangé c'était pour avoir
des contacts plus rapides et plus
directs
il me paraît alors je peux être
nécessaire tout de même d'aborder le
problème qui a été rapidement tout
al'air évoquées par claude bourdet c'est
à dire de parler de l'homme qui a été le
cas et et jean moulin qui au fond a été
la courroie de transmission entre
londres et la résistance alors sur ce
point vous avez un certain nombre
deux positions assez précises entraînait
une chose qui est sûre que personne ne
discute et personne ne discutera jamais
c'est que jean moulin et là des très
grands héros de la résistance personne
ne peut le contester
arrêté dans les conditions que l'on sait
il n'a pas dit un seul mot alors qu'il
détenait tous les secrets par conséquent
nous devons draps avant toute chose
rendre hommage à sa mémoire
ceci étant dit son action a revêtu un
caractère politique
il est donc permis de porter un jugement
dans mon livre
j'émets une hypothèse au profit de
laquelle j'amène un certain nombre
d'arguments qui à mes yeux ont valeur de
preuve mais je sais bien que la
politique car il s'agit de politique
n'est pas une science mathématique c'est
la conclusion à laquelle je suis parvenu
c'est jean moulin a en fait été ce qu'on
appelle un crypto communiste et qu'en
définitive la plupart de ces actions ont
concouru à servir le parti communiste
crypte où féminine hypothèse brutale
comme je je je crois que je m'excuse de
le dire haut débit freiné je crois que
c'est absurde et le coup attention je
peux dire même chose de toi toi mais je
crois qu'il serait intéressant
d'ailleurs nettement les tout à l'heure
à te liam qui lui à l'époque était
communiste ou très proche du parti
communiste kke communiste ça n'est pas
une zone à risque sans exagérer les
programmes ans je savais qu'il était
syndicaliste unitaire et je savais
parfaitement ce que ça voulait dire
dirigeants de syndicats syndicaliste
unitaire ça voulait dire le pc ou tout
cas claude est ce qu on peut faire
remarquer en passant qu'il était avec
nous parce que ce syndicaliste unité
devrait organiser à partir des individus
le mouvement des ouvriers contre
l'occupation que les cinq ans je n'avais
pas pris en charge
je pense d'ailleurs henri le semia je
pense comme j'ai la même opinion que
claude par rapport à son jugement sur
jean moulin qui après tout les take a
bow au radical socialiste de gauche
quand henry en ligne quand henry indique
dans son livre également qu'une des
preuves pour étayer son accusation de
crimes du communisme et l'orientation
politique des gens qui l'avaient choisi
dans son propre cabinet qui sont
chambérod meunier j'en ai au large iron
man march madness qui tous étaient aussi
d'excellents radicaux socialistes qui
avaient tous appartenu plus ou moins
après la guerre qui ce corps était et
qui sont redevenues radicaux socialistes
et est par ailleurs pour en revenir un
autre aspect des choses puisque nous
avons abordé tout à l'heure mais pas
terminées
le problème de nos rapports avec londres
il est bien évident que notre position à
nous en france étaient également sur ce
plan là une position politique parce que
la différence de conception entre le bca
à londres et l'état major allié à
londres avec notre propre position sur
la guerre de guérilla était
fondamentalement différente et ne
pouvait en aucun cas s'accorder
notre problème à nous était d'attaquer
les allemands sur notre territoire par
nos propres moyens et par tous les
moyens y compris le sabotage dont
j'étais chargé y compris d'autres
méthodes comme le faire dérailler les
trains et que pour cela nous avions
besoin de matériel que par conséquent
nous pouvions pas être tout à fait
d'accord avec le point de vue du vsr à 2
me je voudrais donner simplement des
arguments on ne peut pas prendre les aux
arguments que henri fresnay donnes tu
les a comptés autant je les ai comptées
pour tendre à prouver que moulin était
proche du parti communiste mais on peut
de ce fait donné deux indications
la première c'est que les communistes et
nous étions absolument d'accord sur
l'action immédiate boulet boulin était
100% courte et la principale bataille a
été
demoulin du général delestraint des
services de londres pour les raisons
qu'indique tout à l'heure le colonel
passy contre nous et les communistes les
traitements à des accords politiques
deuxième chose deuxième élément très
important aussi c'est que la création du
conseil national de la résistance qui
est une chose sur laquelle il ya un
point d'interrogation sur son utilité
aux riffs rennais pense que c'était
n'efface je crois que c'était si néfaste
aussi les inévitables
c'est très différent moi non mais je
pense sera pas le temps de le prouver je
pense que sache je pense que ça n'a pas
servi particulièrement le parti
communiste en tout cas pendant toute la
période où moulin était là et je pense
que moulins aurait pu dire que c'était
le meilleur moyen de noyer le parti
communiste dans les autres partis pour
compenser l'infériorité politique des
dirigeants de la résistance le colonel
passy je pense mais j'aurais voulu dire
un mot sur le moulin parce que je vais
très bien connu j'ai fait mes sautes par
h et de lorsqu'il a été faire sont
vraiment parachute à la fin de décembre
je les accompagne élevé que pendant huit
jours avec lui entièrement effet tous
mes sauts avec lui et je suis persuadé
pour l'avoir vu bien par la suite et
avoir été en relation très amicale qui
n'a jamais été du tout proche des
communistes je pense partage l'opinion
de glee à mathieu de bourdais ces
lettres persanes ans il pensait qu'il y
avait peut-être des gens inquiétant
aujourd'hui mais quentin le loyalisme de
jean moulin n'a jamais été en cause par
rapport au général de gaulle je veux
vous dire c'est que j'ai vécu aussi les
débuts du conseil national de résistance
et l'idée a été amené par moulin à mon
avis moulin avait une formation de
préfet il avait été un personnage de la
troisième république
son idée était une idée manifestement de
concentrer les pouvoirs et lorsqu'il a
été désigné par le général de gaulle
pour comme son représentant en zone sud
il a réagi normalement comme un haut
fonctionnaire de la troisième république
sous les pouvoirs ici
normalement et il n'a pas accepté de de
se séparer et la balle ça je vis de
l'étranger
je vois que au fond de dissensions dos
mais il reste une chose entre vous et je
trouve ça admirable c'est que bien que
beauchemin a tous soient extrêmement
divergents vous avez entre vous une
sorte de fraternité qui est au fond le
vrai souvenir du combat je voudrais vous
proposer maintenant un autre document
c'est un livre un livre qui a été écrit
par gotlib fuchs gotlib fuchs c'est un
homme c'est un suisse allemand
il a été interprète de barbie barbie
était celui qu'on appelait le bourreau
de lyon c'était le chef de la gestapo à
lyon
gottlieb fuchs a été un homme qui a très
vite travaillé pour la résistance il a
probablement sauvé un certain nombre de
vies humaines en particulier celle de
genre very le docteur jean reversi qui
ensuite est devenu un écrivain
aujourd'hui les morts ça a été un très
grand écrivain et gottlieb fuchs vient
de confier à un journaliste ses
souvenirs
alors ces souvenirs sont très bons il a
été déporté d'ailleurs gotlib fuchs est
un homme extrêmement fatigué un homme
extrêmement malade il est âgé je suis
allé le voir en suisse et voici ce qu'il
m'a dit à la réception
comme d'habitude je vois entrer les
allemands avec lui les prisonniers qui
ont été amenées à la caf lamba les
allemands naturel mais la vie toujours
des sentinelles en bas les amazones sont
partis deux ou trois jours après j'ai vu
un de ces prisonniers qui a dit traînée
par les pieds par barbie 7
ce dôme jeudi est encore assez jeune
il était il saignait de partout ils
étaient frappés probablement avec barbie
parce que quand des leurs revenus barbie
de la caf il m'a dit ah cela s'il est
pas fini
aujourd'hui je finirai demain devant la
barre à pyla
dit dans un bureau et moi tu attendais
quelques quelques minutes après je suis
descendu et j'avais chez ruland membres
de la caf ce promeneur qui est des
seniors il était couché sur le sur le
lente et bien je tournais il avait déjà
ôté il a remis lui avait pas accordé la
baisse de 21
alors je la tourne mais j'ai ôté la vie
complètement je la mettais sur sa tête
et je prends lieu un chiffon le mouchoir
et je l'avais un peu dans c'est à dire
je ferai un peu le sens de loin j'ai pas
j'ai pensé que c'est par une longue il
est mal traitée mais il savait pas
encore le nom de cet angle et je ne sais
pas demandé non plus parce qu'ils
étaient il était incapable de répondre
oui et mappy temps j'ai appris que
c'était monsieur voulait françois michel
gonnot
vous êtes journaliste à combat du combat
actuel et vous êtes né en 1949 c'est à
dire 4 en 5 ans 6 ans sept ans après
tous ces événements alors vous avez lu
le livre de fresnay vous avez vu ces
films vous avez entendu ces messieurs
qu'est ce qu'on pensait tout ça tout
d'abord la première constatation c'est
que même au risque de choquer certains
si monsieur pour moi c'est une histoire
c'est un impasse et que je connais je ne
connais pas que je ne connais qu'à
travers les témoignages que ces hommes
qui l'ont vécue disons ont laissé et
mais le premier sentiment que je tire de
ce débat c'est de la difficulté disons
qu'il y à écrire l'histoire et sur ce
point
disons que c'est avec un grand intérêt
que j'ai lu le livre de monsieur freiné
parce que sur de nombreux points en
particulier sur jean moulin sur les
rapports qui ont tenté d'exister qui ont
existé entre la résistance d'à côté et
londres disons que monsieur freinet va
beaucoup à l'encontre de pas mal de
points de ce que je pourrais dire les
idées reçues d'une doctrine dix ans plus
ou moins officielles par ailleurs du
film je dois dire que j'ai avec quelques
surprises que j'ai constaté comment le
premier combat dix ont été tirés cet
artisanat et musset c'est beaucoup dire
du personnel et par lyon où il organisé
à dire bonjour monsieur martinez
j'aimerais c'est très bien merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
jean pierre melville vous allez tenir
dans ouvrez les guillemets la chronique
la critique du roman policier du roman
d'aventurés ce n'est pas parce que vous
êtes des des films d'aventurés des films
policiers comme nous avons demandé une
heure c'est parce que nous savons que
vous êtes un lecteur infatigable de ses
romans là et alors et finalement pour
vous est ce que ça ne serait pas une
sous littérature finalement le roman
policier
non je ne crois pas car well disait
qu'avec deux genre de littérature la
bonne et la mauvaise et qu'on pouvait
les trouver
l'un et l'autre dans toute la
littérature ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que le roman policier est né dans la
littérature populaire qu'il a été en
quelque sorte l'enfant du mélodrame du
boulevard du crime
c'est pour ça qu'on peut parler de la
littérature policière aussi en disant la
littérature criminel qu'il y avait un
mariage entre le mélodrame et le
romantisme que les premiers romans
policiers en tout cas les deux premiers
la sphère le rouge
gaboriau ne sont pas encore sortis
complètement du romantisme
il ya encore les coïncidences et les
enfants qu'on retrouve plus tard
tout de suite après gaboriau on peut
parler
edgar poe bien sûr aux états unis avec
un personnage tifa son apparition le
premier vrai policier
justement la chance du roman policier
finalement c'est le personnage oui et à
partir de la fin du 19e siècle on va
l'exploiter
on va faire un personnage de série il y
aura d'abord ce rare turc alan doyle qui
inventera sherlock holmes et puis il y
aura en france maintenant plus tard
maurice leblanc tient ventre arsène
lupin ci a beau appartenir à une
littérature populaire comme je le disais
tout à l'heure
mais qui peut être aimé aussi de ancien
polytechnicien comme on en connaît le
site est à côté de moi ici break vous
lisez beaucoup de romans policiers
messieurs devront vraiment de partager
avec jean-pierre passion enfin nous
sommes très forts on peut quand même
passé mois sur les différents noms car
c'est lui pas emprunter ou bien sûr mais
qui est inventé
l'assassin du dernier chapitre ça c'est
agatha christie
tout de suite après la guerre de 14-18
tient avec edgar wallace et aussi avec
un auteur qu'on a complètement oublié
maintenant et j'indique comme cela aux
dépôts et leader qu'ils feraient bien
d'y penser
un homme qui s'appelait philips
oppenheim qui avait inventé l'homme aux
pieds bots et qui est un livre une série
de livres qui ont ravi de mon
adolescence je suis persuadé qu siens
l'éditeur parisien retrouver l'original
de philips oppenheim
il fera de très bonnes affaires romans
policiers et finalement aujourd'hui
c'est le roman américain il faut bien le
dire pour hisser le roman noir ça
changeait de nom c'est devenu quelque
chose d'assez différent et james kane
sont des ventes est lui-même donc je
peux le dire
après avoir usé là et en particulier
thérèse raquin a décidé de traiter neuf
fois de suite paraît-il mais je n'ai pas
lu les neuf l'histoire du mari de la
femme et de l'amant de la maîtresse le
prendre là mais ton posé naturellement
de faire disparaître le gêneur celui
qu'on ne voudrait pas conservé je pense
que très peu d'années après est apparue
une autre forme au coeur de littérature
noire aux etats-unis et c'est la plus
importante parce qu'elle est durable
elle existe encore c'est celle qui a été
en quelque sorte inventé et sacralisé
par byrne est donc en avi
tu étais un livre passionnant
jean pierre melville je voudrais que
vous proposer aux téléspectateurs 6
romans policiers qui sont d'après vous
si chef-d'oeuvre ou en tout cas les six
romans essentiel que vous aimeriez non
je vais être très subjectif je ne suis
pas sûr de faire un choix
exact je crois qu'il faut avoir lu en
tout cas alors première vers l'euro la
sphère le rouge
la rouille oui on trouve au livre de
poche 2 incontestablement une étude et
le canada oui le premier le premier
sherlock la dame suivie dans rouge et
noir allemand alors qu'arsène lupin de
faire ma maison et leurs deux filles
faciles car ce n'est pas notre mannequin
brière de maurice leblanc 4 le meurtre
de roger ackroyd agatha christie très
important 5le james kane
oui le facteur sonne toujours deux fois
ou assurance sur la mort de l'acteur
sonne toujours de mai qui sera rééditée
par poches noires dans un mois environ
et enfin 6e donné droit six titres quand
elvis dehors de bernad
je crois que c'est un bon choix pour la
première semaine en tout cas à bientôt
jean permis
[Musique]
à
mais
[Musique]
ces questions
arthur rubinstein
c'est un extrait du film de françois
reichenbach arthur rubinstein ou l'amour
de la vie arthur rubinstein vient de
publier le premier volume de ses
mémoires
les jours de ma jeunesse publié chez
laffont et françois régime
françois-régis bastide les a lus
françois-régis bastide est romancier
vous êtes directeur de la création de la
collection solfège des éditions du seuil
et évidemment vous connaissez très bien
l'oeuvre d'arthur rubinstein parce que
je connaissais surtout robin stein comme
pianiste
on va voir beaucoup pas entendu mon
niveau national et là j'ai découvert un
robin stein que je n'attendais pas car
quand on dit rubinstein on a toujours
tendance à penser à quelqu'un qui se met
au piano et qui avec beaucoup de
facilité joue généralement chopin avec
un brillant extraordinaire on pense que
c'est très facile
en lisant ce livre je dis tout de suite
un livre de professionnels car c'est
très rare quelqu'un qui a connu une vie
comme celle rubinstein prenne la peine
d'écrire lui même comme un vrai
professionnel
un livre comme celui là qui à 650 pages
et pour lequel vous me laissez
probablement quatre minutes c'est
évidemment est insuffisant alors je ne
peux que je ne peux que dire que dans ce
livre il ya comme on peut le penser
des quantités d'anecdotes des quantités
de concerts des quantités de voyager
tout ce qu'on peut tout ce qu'on peut
attendre de la vie de robinson mais il
ya bien plus il y a pour moi ce qui est
plus important c'est que rubinstein
était ce petit garçon né à l'ofc près de
varsovie qui avait des dons prodigieux
une oreille extraordinaire on est dix
rats pianiste il a donc été pianiste
mais la musique ne semble pas au début
être la base de sa culture
et ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'il
a eu un professeur qui s'appelait altman
qui lui a fait lire des livres
ce qui est très rare chez les musiciens
même aujourd'hui il a lu tout à 11 ans à
12 ans il avait lu les romans cyrus il
avait lu les philosophes et il lisait
plus qu'il ne travaillait la musique il
raconte à ce sujet une aussi jeu mais
nous sommes fichus j'en ai pour une demi
heure au moins
mais y'a un petit tableau que j'aimerais
poser sur cet écran c'est le petit
rubinstein qui préfèrent lire anna
karénine que travailler son piano et
l'or qui a posé sur le pupitre anna
karénine
et puis sa main gauche seul fait d
exercice purement mécanique comme il
faisait tout à l'heure devant les
enfants qui sont là et puis à droite il
ya des cerises à gauchy et des chocolats
et anthony prend des cerises avec la
main droite tantôt du chocolat pendant
ce temps la main gauche travail et
pendant ce temps il y anaqua unis alors
tout n'est pas aussi aussi drôle bien
sûr la vie de ce jeune pianiste car le
livre à 650 pages mais il n'a que 30 ans
quand il définit c'est une vie
finalement très dur c'est très difficile
de tenir aux mines stein ça suppose une
abnégation folle surtout quand on est
très doué pour le bonheur ce qui est le
cadre winstein qui préférait visiblement
le bonheur au travail et puis qui avait
une vie romanesque
je ne veux pas dire à quel point cette
vie romanesque il ya naturellement des
dames il ya du poker il ya un duel il y
a des dettes
il y à des hôtels dont on est chassé
parce qu'on n'a pas de poils payer il ya
des humiliations des humiliations comme
je ne pouvais pas imaginer qu'un grand
musicien comme vous avez pu en connaître
des humiliations
quand il n'a pas eu le prix qui leur est
dû avoir à saint-pétersbourg pour des
raisons raciales il ya bien longtemps de
cela des humiliations aussi parce que
c'est terrible de courir le cachet quand
on ne sait pas encore qu'on va devenir
un des plus grands pianistes du monde je
pensais de cette anecdote vraiment qu'il
racontait goût de charme et de
gentillesse ou une dame lui avait
demandé de venir jouer du piano chez
elle et où il est là il joue du chopin
il n'est pas un concert privé comme on
pourrait le croire mais c'est une dame
est un monsieur à monsieur avec qui il a
des rapports très très galant cette dame
et la robine stein a repoussé les fleurs
clés sur le piano on a soulevé le
couvercle dans le couvert qui joue
chopin et ils voient que cette dame est
ce motion d'une conversation disons
galante et à la fin il part avec ses
2000 lire je crois ça se passait à rome
et c'était de me lire je ne peux pas en
dire beaucoup plus sur ce livre parce
que je n'ai pas le temps ce que je
voudrais dire simplement sais que je
peux être très reconnaissants rubinstein
devrait écrit ce livre
le reste s'il ne l'écrit pas je ne sais
pas où il en est je sais pas s'il a
commencé le deuxième tome
le deuxième tome c'est relativement plus
facile
parce que des quantités de gens peuvent
le raconter celui-là n'y a que vous qui
pouviez le dire et vous l'avez dit avec
une chaleur une tendresse un humour
malgré toutes les pages sombres votre
vie qui font que on peut avoir envie de
devenir winstein quand on est des jeunes
gens des jeunes filles comme ça mais on
s'y reprend à deux fois on a envie
d'être très doué d'abord merci régie
festive et justement on a des enfants
qui sont tous des membres des jeunesses
musicales de france maître ils sont là à
vos pieds ils sont tous élèves du
conservatoire de corbeil-essonnes et il
brûle tous de vous poser des questions
ils ont lu votre loi comme ça des jeux
13 en traction y aille je vous dis une
chose moi je suis tenable et que vous
avez là côté des choses qu'à breuses que
moi à nos jeunes personnes comme ça dans
mon lit dont les repas sans ses délires
là qui veut poser les folies mais selon
lui ils l'ont lu ils l'ont lu quel est
celui qui veut poser la première
question je perds tu quand j'avais votre
âge je lui aussi toujours des livres qui
m'ont été défendues
je veux métiers jean françois qui veut
mais jean françois est trompettiste et
veux vous poser la première question de
tracts chaque fois que je dois donner en
concert je les pires que jamais
maintenant la première fois en or quand
je suis devenu un peu plus grand jeu
qu'on était un petit garçon
non parce que là je vais penser quand
une grande boîte de chocolats comment
avait promis quand j'ai pilé n'est pas
de jouer je n'avait que 6 ans alors là
vraiment c'était un peu tôt mais quand
j'avais déjà 10 ans 12 ans où il fallait
responsable vous
j'avais un professeur très sévère avec
une grande barbe comme ça vous regardez
comme ça alors j'avais une peur
épouvantable a vendu jouer mais une fois
devant les pianos d'habitude ça me dit
ce trac là parce que ça n'est pas il ya
deux manières de tard qu'il ya une
manière c'est d'avoir peur devant le
public
la peur de jouer en public venu ce sont
des gens qui jouent merveilleusement
bien à la maison mais dès qu'il voit un
public alors leurs gens commencent à
trembler l'oublié un peu ce qui se passe
ça ce sont des gens auxquels je
conseille de ne pas donner des concerts
du tout mais l'autre jean les miens ça
c'est le trac la responsabilité devant
les compétiteurs devant l'oeuvre ne
traquent les pas de si on est tout à
fait d'aplomb sur les lyonnais en force
eu si on peut vraiment répondre à toutes
les émotions qu'on s'en va là c'est que
c'est ça frédéric et une fois devant le
piano on perd complètement cette
sensation qui ont les temps leurs voiles
à mettre si vous répondez trop
longuement à ce jeune homme vous allez
mécontenter tout simplement de
rencontrer entre lui et vous savez
qu'ils vont poser des questions terrible
frédéric frédéric deck et flûtiste m que
faites-vous avant et après un concert
que faites-vous avant et après un
concert bien vengé le tac je viens de
raconter cela et mais après ça veut dire
que je baille
je pense que j'ai mal degrés y aura au
brave pas je pense que me dois ne marche
pas je pense que je n'ai pas de mémoire
voilà ça c'est avant le concert après le
concert va dire que peut-être c'est un
phénomène spéciale ne sut jamais fatigué
le même je crois que je suis champion de
ne pas transpirer
je suis l'homme qui ne transpire pas à
l'abri d'un concert ma chemise même avec
un effort énorme dans une salle chaude
reste complètement bonne pour les
prochains concerts
le change quand même que cela suivez
vous et je suis complètement à plat et
puis le seul qui ne suis pas fatigué le
kraken pomme au public
j'ai bien fatigué a plus un long concert
moi pas alors je vais souper avec des
amis ma femme très souvent dans la soupe
et succulent merveilleux on reste très
table avec des amis je suis le seul qui
ne suis pas fatigué à la fin qui le
supplie de rester encore deux sur les
derniers dernier dernier de penser avant
le coucher
voilà sylvie sylvie et guitariste je
vais vendre question
sylvie m vous écrivez vous n'aimez pas
les enfants prodiges
pourtant vous semblez en avoir été un
sylvie vous dis que je n'aime vous
n'aimez pas les enfants prodiges et elle
dit que pourtant vous en avez été un non
non non non non non vous n'êtes que la
question doit être exact
l'enfant prodige qui sont exploitées
évidemment mozart c'était un enfant
prodige isolé en faire adorer vous
comprenez bien et tous nous étions tous
des enfants prodiges comme talent parce
que les talents se révèlent
immédiatement on est né avec un talent
comme avec un sixième sens la même chose
que de voir dans le temps de 11 autres
comme ça mais l'exploitation de l'enfant
prodige voilà où je suis très très très
hostile à cela comprenez ce que je veux
dire le papa et la maman qui promène ce
bébé-là rhdp domaine des circuits belges
où séjournent à faire le père touche
l'argent et avons les promène comme ça
et puis après il y avait un trou ou en
imbécile ou peut-être réussi quand même
dire quelque chose mais c'est très
mauvais pour nous
voilà parce qu'il doit te plantes comme
les autres il doit il doit grandir comme
les autres god mêlée une vie normale
bruno bruno et pianiste m g à nice
oui pianiste alors j'ai lu dans votre
livre cette phrase je reste convaincu
qu'un interprète de talent peut en
oublier tous les morceaux qu'ils jouent
s'il est 1re créateurs et non un simple
exécutant
alors je voudrais savoir comment vous
arrivez à redécouvrir donc à recréer un
morceau que vous avez joué des centaines
de fois je ne découvre pas je vis de
répéter ce que mon cher picasso a dit
vous le rouge on ne tourne cherche pas
on trouvera une recherche constante à
grigny vérité j'ai pas besoin de
chercher longtemps quelque chose comme
ça qu'elle croit développe une idée mofo
c'est l'inspiration du moment vous
chaque jour est différent chaque lumière
différente nous sommes différents chaque
jour nous sommes des êtres différents
parce que c'est justement le jour du du
lendemain despatie surlendemain alors
tout devient différent
les acteurs du monde des affaires de so2
regarde les choses autrement
et bien comme un trou devant les publics
en jouant pour la millième fois la
polonaise de chopin elle devient
complètement nouvelle le gens que je
vois devant moi sont des gens qui sont
censés ne jamais l'avoir entendu avant à
love halak leur raconte quelque chose
avec le nouvel homme que je suis ce soit
là elle à convolution même des biens
tout à fait nouvelle peu moins clair
clair et flûtiste m vous écrivez que
vous ne vous n'aimez pas la poésie car
c'est une musique qui chante faux qui
sonne faux
ne trouvez-vous pas c'est injuste vous
avez appelé ça dans le livre rue mais
vous parlez un certain moment de la
pesée
encore tout cela doit être je ne suis
pas écrivain je vois maintenant que
l'été beaucoup ne savaient pas bien
m'excuser les traducteurs voilà me
voyais bien s'être excusé ils ont
compris que j'ai détesté les enfants
pour dire que je déteste la poésie le
noël où la poésie le considère toujours
comme une cousine de la musique dans
cette entité noblesse énorme pouvoir
ne pensez pas que c'est une chose d
enfin des mépris je racontais seulement
où elle mais gêne parce que comme la
musique exprime de passion très violente
elle fume des choses quelquefois même
tout à fait défendu à sortir tout ce que
voulaient au monde mais elle me permet
d'exprimer puisqu'il n'ya pas des points
tunisie il n'y a pas de paroles la
poésie vous êtes exprimés justement des
sentiments est extrêmement vont pas
quelquefois très violent de choses qui
gênent enfin je sais seulement que quand
j'étais très jeune comme le plus
sensible est un peu honteux de choses
enfin le sensation peu trop violent
justement j'étais gêné quand des jeunes
filles d'eau c'était la mode
commencez à déclamer des vers mais quand
je les ai moi même dans mon lit par
exemple le soin de pleurer quelquefois
d'émotion en l'élisant parce qu'alors
c'était un langage de nouveaux
silencieux vous voyez pénétrer comme la
musique
eh bien m nous allons terminer à la fois
sur la poésie et sur la musique est une
belle feinte pour ouvrez les guillemets
qu'était son numéro 2 de tous vous avez
tout comme genou tout compris à lundi
prochain
bonsoir fermez les guillemets
[Musique]